بالكاد يبلغ من العمر أسبوعين ، من
الواضح أن كوليس في حاجة ماسة إلى والدته ،
لكن هذا الفهد اليتيم هو أحد
المحظوظين الذين تم إنقاذهم من التجارة غير المشروعة في
الحياة البرية عبر القرن الأفريقي
إذا لم تُقتل الأمهات ،
يتم خطف الأشبال منهم ليتم تهريبهم
والصناديق المكدسة وصناديق الكرتون
بحلول الوقت الذي يصلون فيه إلى هذا الملجأ ،
كانوا بالكاد على قيد الحياة
وفقًا لصندوق الحفاظ على الفهد ،
يتم تهريب حوالي 300 شبل من
هذه المنطقة كل عام ومقابل كل
شخص يصل إلى الأسر
يموت ثلاثة آخرون في  الطريقة التي يُعرف بها وادي
داون ماير باسم
سوبر ماركت الفهود ، وذلك لأن العديد من
الفهود المرورية يتم تهريبها
عبر هذه الحدود المليئة بالثغرات مع إثيوبيا
إلى أرض الصومال ، هذه الدولة الانفصالية
عن الصومال هي طريق العبور الرئيسي
لقطط المرور خارج القرن
الأفريقي  تم تهريبهم عبر خليج عدن
إلى شبه الجزيرة العربية ، أصبح الناجون
من الرحلة الصعبة
ملحقًا غريبًا مثل بلينغ المصمم مثل
يتنافس عرب الخليج الأثرياء على النقرات على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
، ويقدر أن ما لا يقل عن ألف فهد
في أيدي القطاع الخاص ،
ووفقًا للخبراء ،
مات معظمهم في الأسر في غضون عام أو عامين
على الرغم من أن الملكية الخاصة وتجارة
الأحياء البرية محظورة في معظم دول الخليج.
بدأت عمليات بيع lacs غير القانونية
عبر الإنترنت في الخضوع للرقابة ،
ولكن إذا كنت تريد حقًا الفهد
، فليس من الصعب العثور على هذا
سوق سعودي عبر الإنترنت وعندما
نبحث عن الفهود ظهرت العديد من القوائم
للإعلان عن اثنين إلى ثلاثة من
الفهود القديمة ، والبعض الآخر يبيع الأشبال الصغار
هذا الرجل في المملكة العربية السعودية حريص على
بيع القليل في دي موين دي
موين الخيالي جياني
ما دينامو زوجي شباب
النافذة عيون أبي غير ممكن و 6600
لنا  يبدو أن الدولارات هي
السعر المبدئي على الإنترنت في المملكة العربية السعودية ،
ولم تستجب الحكومة السعودية لطلب CNN
المتكرر للتعليق ، حيث لم
يتبق سوى 7500 فهد في جميع أنحاء العالم ،
نصف العدد الذي كان عليه قبل عقد من الزمان فقط ، تسبب الأشخاص
الذين لديهم حيوان الفهد حيوانًا أليفًا في حدوث
هذه الأنواع.  انقرضت إنها
تقود الطريق نحو الانقراض السيد بوند هو
أحد الألعاب المفضلة التي وجدناها
وعالمة الأحياء في Oricon Laurie
Marker وصندوق حفظ الفهود التابع لها
يتسابقان لإنقاذ هذا النوع من
الانقراض ، هذه ليست الطريقة التي
يجب أن يعيش بها صغار الفهود التي يحتاجون إليها
لقد أقاموا
هذا المنزل الآمن في أرض الصومال لأنهم يعيشون في البرية من أجل
عمليات الإنقاذ التي تنفجر عند اللحامات
برؤيتهم هنا يكسر قلبي ،
ويمكنك أن ترى لماذا يطلق عليهم الناس القطط
التي تبكي ، ومن مسؤوليتنا
منحهم  أفضل رعاية يمكن أن
يحصلوا عليها ومحاولة إنقاذ كل
واحدة منهم قطة عمرها عشرة أشهر في
العناية المركزة آخر ناجية من
ثلاث شقيقات لم تكن موجودة  من بين
القطط الأكثر صحة لدينا ، أعني أنه من المحتمل أن يكون
لها علاقة كبيرة بالمكان الذي بدأت فيه
في الحياة على الرغم من جهود الفريق كيتي
لم تجعل هذه الحيوانات
أقل عددًا من السكان نادرًا
جدًا ومن ذلك كل واحد منهم
يحمل  رمز جيني مختلف ، هذا هو
ذكر كل شبل يحصل على شريحة دقيقة
يتم تسجيل الحمض النووي الخاص به بدون أم
يجب تعليمه كيفية الصيد
والبقاء على قيد الحياة في البرية. يستغرق الأمر أحيانًا
شهورًا لمحاولة الحصول على فهد واحد للوقوف
على قدميها.
سمينًا هو
مقدم الرعاية الرئيسي لهم ، حتى أنني لا أرى والدتي
ضعيفة جدًا لدرجة أنها تعيش هناك
وفقًا للعلامة ، لا يوجد سوى حوالي
300 بالغ في مناطق غير محمية في
القرن الأفريقي إذا قمت بحساباتك ، فإن
نوع الرياضيات يظهر ذلك  لن يستغرق
الأمر سوى بضع سنوات حتى
لا يكون لدينا أي فهود في هذه
المنطقة ، وقد فقد الكثير منها بالفعل
بسبب الصراع مع البشر ، حيث
تقوم سلطات الحياة البرية في أرض الصومال
بخرق المهربين ، إنه غير قانوني هنا
وحدنا  g مع ملكية خاصة ولكن في
العاصمة ، غييشا لها مطعم شهير
يعلن عن البرغر والأسود
الأسيرة في الخلفية لالتقاط صور سيلفي لمدة
ثلاث سنوات ، كان هذا الفهد على حبل قصير
هو نقطة جذب العملاء لدفع
العملاء لكزة الحيوانات الأليفة والتقاط الصور مع
المالك.  إنه ترخيص قانوني
بالإضافة إلى أنه يوجد فهد واحد فقط هنا
ولديه الكثير من هواء الفضاء للتجول حول
سبب التسامح معه على مرأى من الجميع.
تمت مصادرة منزل رخيص من منزل هنا
في ديزا الخاصة بها ، حيث
تم الاستيلاء على ثلاثة آخرين بعد أيام
قليلة فقط طالما أن هناك طلبًا من قبل
الأثرياء مما أدى إلى إنشاء تجارة مربحة
للفقراء ، فإن مستقبل الفهود معلق في
الميزان
الوقت ليس بجانبهم جيمانا  كراتشي
CNN لها بوابات أرض الصومال